Now, you can't plan ahead.
But this is an opportunity.
How many times you get an opportunity, it's DA DA DA DA DA DA! Do the song, right?
That Bond song from Your Eyes Only feels like a Bill Conti song to me.
You know, we hear the bassoon.
We hear those moments that make you think that's Bill Conti.
Good.
Well, that kind of identity, if it happens,has to do with technique.
David Rose, you know who, David?
Of course I do.
Well, he wrote The Stripper, Holiday for Strings, Little House on the Prairie, Bonanza.
So after my Rocky moment, these composers that I admired,
I was now allowed into their company, right?
So David says, You know, what's going to happen to you?
I said, No, David, what?
He says "Well, I've been called a string man."
Holiday For Strings. He says, they want something weepie with strings.
They think of me.
When people think of or they want something brass and heroic,
They're going to think of you.
And those are the kind of pictures you're going to get.
Even though you're able to do many others.
Hollywood, he says, likes to stamp you as a brand.
Now, I'm just quoting what he said. That's what he felt, that's for sure.
It's always about the brave person who who who dares to do something different
That changes fashion in the first blast.
You do that with the Rocky score.
You do that with that For Your Eyes Only score.
Those because those and those song,
Because those songs are getting poppier and poppier.
In a contemporary way that was a date stamp on those movies.
That song, Sheena Easton singing, suddenly it feels.
like it could be a, it could be a throwback to something like to Laura or that kind of thing.
It was..there was.. in fact, it was one of the more lush and romantic Bond songs that I ever heard.
If I could interject like a Dusty Springfield,
You wish Dusty Springfield.
So that's what I was going for, something like that.